this shouldn't be done because there is
a question mark on his Islam there is a
big question to go and join a force who
is actively massacring your brothers and
sisters just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends when I heard these news I was as
shocked as you guys were I didn't know
that there are Muslims who are serving
in the
IDF it shocks you it genu genely
genuinely shocks you I don't know if
these people are uh there's firstly a
big question mark when it comes to the
scholars on this person's Islam or these
individuals Islam for you to serve in
the army yes I don't know if it's
something that's forced or whatever that
matter I don't want to talk big but I
would rather die or be killed or be shot
in the back of the head then know that
I'm going to go to Gaza and I'm going to
go and Massacre my own brothers and
sisters innocent men women and children
you know in this in this in this matter
so this is the funeral prayer when I
first heard this I thought like this for
real some kind of a joke yeah no it's
true uh this person Abul Latif or I
don't know his name for that matter um
who was killed in Gaza yes by the
resistance um let's watch it for ourself
uh cuz I'm I'm taken back doing even
doing this video like let's watch the
video inshah and watch the funeral
prayer a Muslim I Soldier was murdered
yesterday you heard that right according
to the his name was Ahmed AB
clearly nobody's really crying or sad
for his death but anyways enjoy the
Hereafter so guys Subhan Allah as you
can see now I've spoken to my teachers
my my teacher said very clearly yep
there's maybe opinions here and there
when it comes to you know you students
do the janaza prayer but but the
scholars uh you know the majority of the
view is that this person's Islam is in
question this there's a big question
mark the fact that it's not he was just
even sympathizing for that matter even
that is like weird but for him to go and
outright join the IDF in the
Battleground on the front lines against
the resistance or whoever for that
matter and get killed they use the
evidence
from when he wrote a letter to his
family uh or the mush or along those
lines if I'm not mistaken that the
Muslim armies are coming and this letter
was obviously by wah that the prophet
ordered to go there was a woman carrying
this and subh Allah they found this
letter they opened it they
confronted and said let me hit the neck
of this mafic you outright this this is
hypocrisy and obviously ha made it very
clear that he had no intentions of
treachery or that he he has he's he's
doubting his religion for that matter it
was none of that and the prophet said
indeed fought in B of Battle of bad and
and battle of bad Allah has forgiven
them so this is a unique instance for
that scenario but Allah subh says in the
Quran very specifically inah and if two
group of Believers fight each other then
make peace between them but if one of
them transgresses against the other then
fight against the transgressing group
until they are until they come to the
command of Allah and if they do so then
make peace between both groups in all
fairness and act justly surely Allah
loves those who uphold Justice in this
matter there is not a group that you can
talk to you are somebody in the
battlefield who was wearing the Garment
of these genocidal Maniacs yes you went
there
and you got what you deserved you got
liquidated there's a big question on
your Islam and that's what the prophet
PE said Aid your brother either if he's
oppressed or the oppressor so the
companion said we know how to Aid the
oppressed yes our brother and sisters in
Gaza yes we know how to Aid them yes
alhamd all of us are collectively trying
to do that but how do we Aid the
oppressor he said by stopping his
oppression his family the people around
him should have should have told this
guy to never ever join these absolute
scums of this Earth yes who don't even
care they would rather send the Muslims
go and fight the Muslims do you think
they care do you think the idea of care
do you think this Benjamin Satan yah and
the rest of these individual do you
think they're going to shed the tear for
you who was it they're going to find out
who was it it's a Muslim idea okay no
problem send more of them to the front
let them kill each other yes that is
what's going to happen so doing a janaza
pray on this person the scholars say
that they shouldn't be done because
there is a question mark on is Islam
there is a big question mark on Islam to
go and join a force who is actively
massacring your brothers and sisters so
much so that you go to Gaza at least go
if you're know that I'm say you should
you know if you're going to go do
something or wash the dishes or
something I don't know yeah may Allah
subhana tala we don't want to I don't
want to speak of uh his death his
affairs with Allah subhana
tala if he was a Muslim may Allah
subhana wa tala forgive him if he was
not a Muslim may Allah subhana double
his punishment yes shame on him and if
he's a Muslim and he done this knowingly
may Allah subhana wa tala exper his sins
in the punishment of the grave in the
Hellfire yes if Allah subh chose to
forgive he Forgives I am just shocked to
see that Muslims are joining these dirt
bags who were committing Massacre and
genocide Subhan Allah may Allah subhana
T protect us that's all I wanted to say
it is shocking and if there's anyone
watching this who is in the IDF fear
Allah subhana wa tala they are
massacring your brothers and sisters how
do you take steps towards going there
taking steps towards this massacre this
genocide that's why I saying your
humanity is gone you've got a dead heart
may Allah correct Affairs and may Allah
subhana wa tala destroy this government
this regime this government inshallah
brothers and sisters may Allah bless you
guys inshah till next
time just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on y that you read it wherever you
was